[Music]
did you know that the great pyramid of
giza is the last of the seven wonders
that still stands
built over 4 000 years ago under the
orders of the egyptian king khufu it
attracts tourists from all around the
world and contains mysteries that
scholars are still trying to solve
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives three
historians discuss how the great pyramid
was built and some of its 4 000 year old
secrets
we begin by taking a look at the great
pyramid size and the incredible feat of
its construction enjoy
[Music]
the great pyramid was built on the giza
plateau near modern cairo egypt the
mysterious sphinx sits nearby staring
towards the east
two other very large pyramids were
nearby plus seven small pyramids next to
the big one
all around the pyramids are cemeteries
tombs and mortuary temples
the purpose of the pyramids
were as tombs for the pharaohs
we know this from the remains of the
site as well as from the various texts
written in hieroglyphs
these writings included the pyramid
texts and the book of the dead
these show a rich set of religious
rituals and instructions for how the
pharaoh could journey through the
dangers of the underworld and reach the
afterlife
the placement of tombs and pyramids on
the west side of the nile river was due
to the symbolism associating the
underworld with the setting sun in the
west
the pyramid is made up of over 2 million
blocks of limestone and granite with the
largest block weighing near 80 tons wow
the stone blocks were all queried nearby
transported across denial by barge and
and offloaded from moving along a
causeway from the edge of the nile to
the pyramid
estimates are that 20 000 workers
labored for 20 years
construction started around the year
2554 bc
all the uncertainties in old egyptian
chronology are a century or more
the great pyramid is connected with the
pharaoh khufu
who's also known by the greek version of
his name as keops
the pharaohs associated with the smaller
pyramids at giza are kafrei and menkauri
and they're all successive rulers the
fourth dynasty of the old kingdom
although we know very little about khufu
we know he was born at the end of the
26th century bce
and lived more than 26 years
he was the son of king sneferu the
greatest pyramid builder of all time
the only named portrait of khufu is a
small ivory statuette just three inches
high
the irony is striking
khufu is often portrayed negatively in
ancient texts the westcard papyrus a
collection of stories written in the
late middle kingdom describes khufu as
heartless and inquisitive
in the papyrus khufu's sons speak in
turn telling tales for their father's
amusement
the fourth story tells of a magician
named daddy who has the power to
reattach an animal severed head to its
body among other things
daddy performs his magic successfully
before the king
khufu then decides to test the magician
and brings a condemned prisoner to be
decapitated
daddy is outraged
it is against the god's will
the fifth century bce greek historian
herodotus wrote that kiops the greek
name for khufu was a tyrant who enslaved
his people and the first century ce
jewish historian josephus claimed the
hebrews built the pyramids yet the
largest pyramids were constructed over a
thousand years before the hebrews
arrived in egypt still this idea
persists in popular imagination
despite khufu's bad press
the ancient egyptians revered him
the egyptians celebrated king khufu's
cult nearly 2 000 years after his death
some egyptologists suggest khufu saw
himself as the incarnation of the sun
god
ra
khufu's son king jedif ray called
himself the son of ra
the great pyramid is awesome in many
ways
part of this is a spectacular feat of
engineering
part of this is that the square base of
the pyramid has its edges accurately
aligned north south and east west
that is the alignment is cardinal
the awesome part of this is that the
alignment is accurate to one twentieth
of a degree an angle equal to one tenth
of the parent size of the moon in the
sky that's just a deviation of eight
inches or 20 centimeters over the entire
230 meter baseline on the side
this is astounding accuracy
to achieve in surveying the lines
to say nothing the achievement of
building along those lines in stone
such a true north-south alignment can
only be made with astronomy
archaeological remains and hieroglyphic
texts can give us some clues as to the
alignment method
texts and inscriptions from before and
after the fourth dynasty describe a
ceremony called
stretching of the cord
with the pharaoh personally helping to
determine the layout for the corners of
the temples
some of the texts tell of the pharaoh
gazing at stars to the north while
others in the text tell about the use of
shadows well
two types of artifacts have been
identified as being included with
alignment ceremony they're both sticks
with markings and indentations they're
called marquette and bay
we've no idea how they were used
although various proposals have been
made
with all this there's no agreement as to
the alignment method and many ideas are
still outstanding
the ceremony does tell us more in that
the ancient egyptians had astronomical
observations central to their beliefs
and these beliefs concerned the pharaoh
himself
what is the function of the two
mysterious air shafts in the king's
chamber in the great pyramid
on two opposite walls of the king's
chamber
at a gentle angle to two rectangular
shafts approximately nine by eight
inches begin their journey through the
body of the pyramid continuing all the
way to the exterior
these shafts have been known for
centuries
but their purpose is not
it's been speculated that they were
constructed to provide air to the
workers as they labored deep inside the
pyramid
this is nonsense
such small shafts with no way to
circulate air could not possibly have
done any good
the clue to their purpose may be a
second set of similar air shafts inside
the queen's chamber
the queen's chamber is not really the
queen's chamber
the king's chamber right in the middle
of the pyramid was intended for hoofer's
final resting place
but what if the king died before the
pyramid was completed
what if the pyramid hadn't reached that
height yet
the queen's chamber was hufu's plan b
much closer to ground level
it could have been used if the pharaoh
died near the beginning of the pyramid
construction
it's in this room that two more air
shafts were discovered in 1872 by weyman
dixon a young engineer sent to egypt to
build a bridge across the nile near giza
dixon discovered the shafts but never
figured out their purpose or why they
went there
he set fires inside the shaft to see if
smoke exited on the outside of the
pyramid it didn't
and to this day we don't know where the
shafts in the queen's chamber end i
think the purpose of the air shafts was
to give huffus ba access to the world of
the living
that's why when the queen's chamber was
being built they put in the shafts
there was even a little symbolic door
but khufu's bar never used these shafts
remember the queen's chamber was only
plan b
later when the pyramid had reached the
height of khufu's burial chamber khufu
was alive and well so he wasn't going to
be buried in the queen's chamber
they had to put in a second set of
shafts for the king's chamber so they
would be close to where the mummy was
going to be placed
so false doors were really a big deal
the casing stones at the base of the
great pyramid of khufu display one of
the most remarkable feats of stone
carving in the world
kufu's stone masons fitted together
seven to 15 ton blocks of stone with
joints so fine that not even a razor
blade can slip between them
how did the egyptians achieve this
amazing feat
when the builders began the pyramids
foundation pavement
and the bottom course of the casing they
set the cornerstones and several center
stones on each face to establish the
line
in the quarry
stone cutters dressed only the bottom of
the stone to fit precisely with the rock
below it
the stone was then hauled to its
intended place on the pyramid
once placed the side joint faces of the
stone were dressed so they fit the
neighboring stone
the slope was marked on the joint face
and moved to life flush with its
neighbor stone now the upper face was
labeled
part of the stone was still overhanging
the stone course beneath
where the two neighboring stones touched
each other
extra stock on the front of the block
was beveled away from the slope line the
unfinished stock was left like this to
help anchor the stone delivery ramps
that rose with the pyramid
once the pyramidian was placed the
masons dressed the extra stock on the
front of the block working from the top
of the pyramid down as they removed the
delivery ramps
they chipped away the excess stone on
the pyramid face so that the spaces
between each block would gradually close
when the joint was so small a knife
blade could not slip between the joints
the masons knew they could not cut any
deeper into the stone they had reached
the desired plane of the pyramid face
the great pyramid has attracted vast
amounts of attention from fringe
thinkers there's even a word for it
pyramidology
early examples are claims that the
dimensions of the great pyramid encode
the number of days in a year the
mathematical constant pi
the golden ratio
and the date of the start of world war
one
for a recent example one internet site
finds deep significance in the fact the
great pyramid easter island and
stonehenge form a triangle on the earth
well of course three points form a
triangle
another favorite claim of
pyramidologists is called pyramid power
this idea flourished back in the early
1970s with extensive press coverage
its claim is that the basic pyramid
shape
channels unknown powers
so pyramid-shaped containers were said
to preserve food to sharpen razor blades
and to trigger sexual urges
back as a young kid i spent a lot of
time making pyramid models putting food
and razor blades into them and testing
them against other identical stuff
placed into cubic containers
this sort of procedure is called a
control experiment where two tests are
made with only one difference between
the two cases so that any difference in
the outcome can be directly attributed
to the one changed situation
in my experiments the only difference
was in the shape of the container
i found zero difference in the rotting
of meat and the sharpness of the razors
so this means that the shape of the
container is irrelevant
this is the core of the scientific
method where we let nature tell us about
reality
well many other people have tried
similar experiments including
mythbusters back in 2005.
these have all been miserable failures
for pyramid power
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here